good afternoon my name is Jim Neal I'm
the university librarian at Columbia and
I'd like to welcome you to this program
which is jointly sponsored by the
library's scholarly communication
program and by the Graduate School of
Arts and Sciences each year we organized
a series of programs looking at key
developments and issues in the work of
research universities and the work of
scholars and students today we tackle a
pretty momentous topic the future of
higher education if you will how can
colleges and universities remain viable
and effective in producing successful
graduates and enabling productive
faculty in addressing national and
global challenges and advancing our
cultural and intellectual vitality our
speaker is Mark Taylor dr. Taylor is
chair of the department of religion at
columbia professor of the philosophy
religion at Union Theological Seminary
and professor emeritus of humanities at
Williams College he has many awards
including the guggenheim fellowship and
the Carnegie Foundation National
professor of the Year award he is a
leading figure in our debates in the
Academy about post-modernism he has
written on topics ranging from
philosophy religion literature art and
architecture to education media science
technology in economics he has a very
wide view of the University and where it
fits into our national and global
perspective he received the doctor grad
in philosophy from the University of
Copenhagen in 1981 a BA from Wesleyan in
1968 and a PhD in religion from Harvard
in 1997 in addition he has played a very
major role in introducing new
technologies to the classroom in 1998 we
were talking about this before before
the session began he co-founded a
company called global education network
whose mission was to introduce high
quality online education in the arts
sciences and humanities to anyone
anywhere in the world perhaps he'll come
out on that experience in his talk we
all know about his new york times op-ed
piece in 2009 and the wide reading and a
huge debate that it engendered we now
have his book crisis on campus which
really expands on and refines some of
the ideas he presented in that op-ed
piece we welcome dr. Taylor we look
forward to his remarks will follow his
presentation with a response from dr. Lu
and then we'll open it up for your
questions and your comments as well dr.
Taylor thank you very much delight to be
here and thank you all for coming and
sharing this time I want to begin by
introducing you to my grandchildren this
is Selma who's just a little over four
and she was here this weekend or father
is running in the marathon and once
again I was blown away by the facility
with which she navigates the computer
her little sister is Elsa who when this
was taken was about six months old and
I'm worried about their future I'm
worried about the future of both our
undergraduate and graduate students
because I don't think we're doing a very
good job educating our young people and
I don't think that what we are doing is
sustainable I think it's unsustainable
financially institutionally and
curricular Lee and I'll try to I'll try
to indicate each of those in in remarks
that Paolo let me contextualize sort of
how I came to an introductory remarks
suggested some of this for over 20 years
I think it is I've been sort of
experimenting with the use of various
technologies in my classroom
in 1992 I taught a course with a
colleague in Helsinki using
teleconferencing I was the first time
that kind of thing had been done and it
was a remarkable experience and began to
show me the kinds of things that these
new technologies might enable educators
to do but I come at this really as
somebody interested in philosophy and
religion I know that a lot when you list
that all the different kinds of things
that I've thought about a written on it
seems like a hodgepodge but there is a
certain logic at least looking back on
it and those experiments grew out of
things that I was thinking about in my
research and writing at the time and
since then the work that I've done in
these new technologies has has really
informed my research and writing and one
of the ways that I have been able to do
this has been to enter into a
collaborative relationship with my
students for many years over 35 years of
Williams with very very bright and able
undergraduate students who unlike many
graduate students unfortunately are
willing to take risks and I became a
student my students my wife is head of
information technology at Williams and
that helps because I really don't
understand a lot of what goes on under
the hood but if I can imagine that the
students can do it and they can imagine
many things I didn't know we might be
able to do so that's been sort of the
context in which I begun to think about
some of these things I also want to say
something else about this context higher
education has to be understood in my
judgment systemically it's a higher
education system of which places like
Williams in Columbia are one small part
much smaller than where want to realize
it seems to me it's a complex and a
diverse system and it's a system that is
in considerable trouble as as we speak
indeed just yesterday the president of
the University of California system
which of course his is being dismantled
as
under our very eyes sent out yet another
dire warning to the people of California
about the economic problems they they
are facing they're still there's still
over their budget is still over 1
billion dollars in in the red and the
cuts that that that will have to entail
the range is also global we have to
understand the edge our educational
system not only in relationship to other
institutions of higher education in this
country but in relationship to other
educate other system education systems
abroad for many many years American
higher education has been the envy of
the world and indeed it still is in many
many ways but that's changing higher
education in this country is a
multi-billion if not trillion dollar
business and it is being it is it is
going to be it's an area that is going
to be be that other countries are going
to in China and India as we speak of
developing strategies to to enter the
American higher education market not by
bringing our students there but by
setting up their operations here so we
have to look at it globally we also have
to look at it it seems to me in
relationship to things that are going on
through in K through 12 and I'll come
back to that in a minute one of the
difficulties that I have had in trying
to address these issues is getting
colleagues in higher education to
acknowledge that there's a problem you
look at California you don't need to
persuade those people but for many other
colleagues we do have a problem there's
a very interesting book it's a book on
businesses title the mighty the mighty
fall why some companies never give in
and Collins has a five sort of a
five-step analysis of of this and his
point is that when the seeds for the
decline of a company and I want to say
it's the same in the university now when
the seeds for decline are already in
place these these
these are at the top of their game they
are extraordinarily successful in doing
very very well in retrospect you can see
that everything was in place for what is
going to follow like that's more or less
where many and a many in higher
education think we are now that very
success leads to what he calls the
undisciplined pursuit of more and we
have seen that repeatedly in the 90s and
the first decade of the 21st century
i'll come back to some of that i think
we see it here locally I think
manhattanville represents precisely that
kind of a problem for Columbia Columbia
is currently carrying as far as I can
figure although they're very it's very
hard to get these figures accurately and
I ask the Provost's office for figures
and they don't give them to me so i'm
i'm not i'm not sure i'm pretty sure
these figures are right but there are
others i would like to have but i can't
get columbia currently has 1.4 billion
dollars debt on a five point eight nine
billion dollar endowment manhattanville
is projected at 6.3 billion dollars
there's going to have to be considerable
borrowing to to to do that our
competitor downtown and why you as you
may know announce this summer that
they're going to expand their physical
plant by forty percent in the next X
number of years NYU is currently
carrying 2.22 billion dollars debt on a
2.2 billion dollar endowment that's not
a mortgage I would want to be carrying
this expansion and I'll come back to
that in a minute leads to very often a
denial of risk and peril and that denial
and I think that's a stage in which many
in higher education are now a denial of
the magnitude of the problem my
suspicion is that administrators
understand the problem much better than
many faculty are willing to but many
administrators can't publicly admit it
the refusal to admit only exacerbates
the problem and leads to eventual
decline and claps one of the things that
I've been struck by as I've studied this
is the as I said there's there's been
extraordinary attention given to factor
K through 12 and rightly so but we have
to understand k through 12 as part of
the same system that colleges and
universities are and that link has not
been been made adequately there's a very
good book by Clayton Christian side of
it you know him or not he made his name
for book called the innovators dilemma
if you haven't if you haven't read that
book I would recommend it to you it he
studied silicon d he's at Harvard
Business School he studied Silicon
Valley extensively and it's a it's a
book whose lessons extend beyond the
area in which he concentrates this book
disrupting class is not social class
although it's related to that it's it's
a book on k to 12 gives this projection
of the delivery of courses online and
because it's hard to read that in the
fall of two thousand or 45,000 online
this is for high school kids 42,000
online courses either online or hybrid
courses being offered by 2007 there were
1,000,000 being offered and Christensen
who's pretty pretty savvy projects that
by 2019 fifty percent of all high school
courses will be offered online that's an
astonishing fact and part of what I
worry about with salma and else is that
the kind of education they will become
accustomed to will not fit with the kind
of education that will be available to
them when they get to college unless we
change the way we do business some of
you may have seen the article in the
education supplement to the New York
Times on Saturday reporting on a survey
that was done of there was 99 different
studies and again this comes as news to
mitty within the university community
that online and I quote online education
on average was as effective or more
effective than face-to-face education
again a significant fact I said that the
problems that higher education is
unsustainable financially
institutionally and curricular Lee let
me look at each of them briefly when I
look at the problem financially I look
under these four categories I want to
look at two sides one from the side of
the students and one from the side of
the institutions and this what I look at
this from the side of the institution's
I will consider in terms of assets
liabilities costs and income from the
side of the students we all have seen
the figures about the increase in the
call intuition relative to the CPI over
the years they've always remained
abstract to me so what I did was I
decided to calculate actual dollars
amounts taking the cost of a Columbia or
Williams education today and projecting
it out 2,000 for the class of two
thousand and twenty all the way through
someone else's school and I figured this
at about six percent overall cost
Columbia's modeling I am told at about
five percent if you look at if you look
at the 2022 21 the cost of you can see
how I've divided up here but the cost of
four years at an institution like this
will be roughly 350 thousand dollars by
the time my older granddaughter is ready
for school b29 2013 20 29 to 2030 it'll
be roughly 590,000 and by the time poor
little else is ready for school it'll be
roughly seven hundred and eighty eight
thousand dollars now when you actually
run those numbers and people look at
them the immediate response is what it's
not sustainable and you say correct but
what are we going to do about and that's
where the conversation stops from the
institutional side let's look at let's
look at the four categories assets are
down and they're not going to go up
significantly we haven't completely
recovered from
the crash of 2008 I don't think we'll
ever get back to where we were before
that last year charitable donations
nationwide not just for colleges and
universities but for everything we're
down eleven percent that's not going to
improve it seems to me liabilities are
up are up and a lot of that liability
comes from excessive borrowing during
the 1990s and early part of this century
many institutions became involved in a
building arms race many of the buildings
that they built were not for educational
purposes but they were athletic don't
enforced our dorms recreational centers
and the like and they borrowed heavily
for that harvard universe it has any
debt I don't know I honestly don't like
I can't figure it out but they are
paying 518 million dollars per year
until twenty thirty eight to service
their current debt Middlebury College
fine small liberal arts school is
carrying 770 million dollars debt on an
endowment that's now as far as I figure
close to seven hundred million dollars
can't sustain it you can't sustain it
costs are either fixed or increasing
right we all know the measures that
we've been asked to take to cut costs
but it's very very difficult to cut to
cut enough to make a significant dent in
all this an income income takes various
forms obviously especially at a place
like Columbia where we have income from
Grants and everything but with respect
to tuition and the like we sell our
product for two-thirds what it costs to
produce it now you don't need an MBA
from Columbia to know that that's not a
viable operation the model for the
University and it's not just because I
teach philosophy at the model for the
University that we have really goes back
to Emmanuel Khan who published a little
essay in 1798 called the conflict of the
faculties he lays out the blueprint for
that for the university the research
University as we've come to know it in
that essay and the first implementation
of that was the University of Berlin
which was found in 1810 whose first
wreck rector was fichte philosopher and
where my guy Hagel and his competitor
schleiermacher lectured during the at
the height of their career it's an
extraordinary this is the first
paragraph of the essay and it's
extraordinary paragraph it seems to me
considering it was published in nineteen
1798 I've highlighted some of the
sections all use the model of mass
production use them all of division of
labor right for the setting up of
departments and divisions which I'll
talk about more he the fundamental
principle of konyen philosophies a
pencil of autonomy he sets up the
university as autonomous visa V the
surrounding world he sets up departments
as autonomous visa V each other and as
anybody who's tried to manage any any
academic position situation knows
there's nothing more autonomous and then
attended professor he set up scholar he
set up peer review scholars passing
judgment on on other scholars and
special day so this structure right and
he divides the university into two
faculties what he calls the higher
faculties in the plural and the lower
faculty the higher faculties are the
professional schools at that time law
medicine and theology the lower faculty
which is one is the philosophical
faculty and that faculties function is
criticism and it includes all of what
today we have under the rubric of of the
Arts and Sciences the time at which
Conte was developing his university was
the time in which he was a shift from
there basically been three patronage
systems in higher education in history
right church state and private conch was
writing at the time of the transition
from church to state right so the
university as he designed it was worked
out in relationship to the emergence of
the modern nation-state and the
so-called higher faculties were those
that would supply the needed workforce
for the emergent nation merging
nation-state those faculties members of
those faculties did not have academic
freedom but were subject to censure on
the part of the state the lower faculty
which is philosophical and includes all
the all these
rules I think as far as I can figure
that's why when you get a doctorate in
chemistry it's a doctorate in philosophy
that it's under that kind of general
faculty its function is criticism and
there is there is academic freedom
related to that that model stays stays
operative all the way down to the to the
present day but it has interesting
implications it seems a certain logic to
it and that logic it seems to me is
something that now that we now need to
rethink again what I mean as I said I I
think about these things in
philosophical terms so the way I'm
trying to understand this is the place
of the University in the larger world
and the place and the way in which the
changes that have taken place in the
last in the last half of the 20th
century have impacted that world and the
university by extension I think the most
important shift that has taken place is
not so much the emergence of what people
talk about as information society but
the emergence of what I talk about is
networked culture the world didn't
change when he introduced information
processing machines the world changed
when we link them up it's created a new
infrastructure we see that
infrastructure in the world of finance
we see it in the world of media it's
also operative in the University and
these networks and I'll talk about this
more have a different operational logic
right and that different operational
logic calls for a different structure of
knowledge and a different structure of
knowledge calls for a different
institutional structure and the
different institutional structure calls
for a different kind of activity within
that structure the industrial model is
basically one we all know mass
production as concept which entails a
certain kind of standardization one of
the questions I began to ask and one for
which I don't have any answer is about
the courses we teach why is every course
more or less the same length why do we
have a set number of courses at Williams
is 32 under that is that are required in
order to graduate why is college four
years or it's all quantitative
standardized model need not be so
the structure this structure is
hierarchical I'll come back to that in a
minute it involves a linearity that goes
with it and it is a world of walls it
seems to me or of different kinds of
silos since with libraries I thought
we'd try to talk a little bit about
different kinds of search technology
except I hesitate because I may get it
all wrong but the Dewey Decimal System
think of it as a search as a search
technology right which we divide ever
everywhere and then think about the way
in which we structure our courses the
increasing the increase in number of
courses rep as as courses as students
progress through a series of courses
very often in a linear kind of sequence
although that too will vary from field
to field an area to area some areas I
mean you do have to know certain kind of
math because and do a certain kind of
science is not as necessary in some of
the humanities it seems to me but
there's a movement toward increasing
specialization and with that has come an
increasing fragmentation and I think
both of those are problematic because I
think and I'll come back to this I think
one of the problems with the university
as we now know it and certainly at the
graduate level is the degree of hyper
specialization in the religion
department that I chair we have 10
full-time faculty members we work with
Barnett we also work with UTS we have
eight subfields makes no sense and it's
not sustainable right and until recently
those subfields were as autonomous again
caught as philosophy and history are and
a student from admission to
comprehensives to thesis would only work
within the subfield with maybe one
course or two courses that would link
across those fields it's not the world
the way the world structured then we
divide into further division divisions
departments that and these are very we
all know this as we try to as we try to
cooperate and collaborate across like
Willy Columbia is better than most and
sort of many of the Institute's and
centers that they have but power is
still distributed by discipline them by
department right
and and power basically means means
money and positions in all this what
would it be like to think differently
what would it be like to imagine a
different structure for the university
see I don't think the way in which
knowledge is structured is hardwired I
think the way in which knowledge is
structured changes with the with the
forms of production and reproduction in
a given society and as those as those
forms change so will the structure of
knowledge and so too often now the
structure of the institution and the
structure of knowledge at odds with each
other when I had the idea to create
global education network one of the
questions I ask myself is what would it
be like to create an educational
institution this is going to be online
now at that time it would be this has
become much more familiar in the last 12
years but at that time it wasn't very
familiar I think that's one of the
reasons we failed but what would it be
like to create an educational
institution structured like a network
rather than a series of silos how would
that look and I've continued to think
about that I think we would move and
again these are terms that are used in
other areas from mass production to mass
customization I'll come back to that in
a minute I think the structure would be
much more decentralized and distributed
I think the core would be in trouble in
this model I think the order would be
much less linear much more nonlinear in
terms of how one progresses through it
and I think it would look much more like
a wall than a series of much more like a
web or than a series of of walls or
silos I think schematically this is one
of the ways I try to look at again these
are all schematic of the ways in which
these different fields intersect for me
where they overlap and and intersect and
all this is in constant motion and
development here's another search engine
right this is a structure of Google
architecture right so what if what if
that architecture became something like
the way in which we organized knowledge
so that we would not necessarily have
departments and divisions but we would
have problem oriented both side that
would cut across disciplines and across
problems we've started to try to do that
in the religion department I said when I
came we had eight subfields and 10
faculty it's important to have
specialization it's important to know
about different traditions unlike but
that's necessary but not sufficient all
right action takes place at the
interspecies that's where creativity
occurs we all know that it's where stuff
crosses over it's in that liminal space
that the new emerges so what we've done
has been to identify after a year of
study five problem-oriented we call them
Jones of inquiry they cut across
disciplines and across traditions we
have body which includes race gender and
the like but eventually will include
things like neuroscience of biomedical
ethics we have space which includes
everything from sacred space and
architecture to cyberspace migrations
and the like we have time and modernity
different notions of temporality and
different ideas of modernity we have
transmission which looks at the
different ways institutional textual
other other worth that that different
religions or cultural formations are
transmitted and we have media which
includes everything from writing to
speech to internet
to mosaics and even to to ghosts it's a
way of trying to create spaces for
discussion between and among these
different areas again to the extent that
there's a vision behind the alternative
structure that I'm looking at it is this
notion of networks and networking a lot
of the work that I've done in the last
10 years has been work in theories of
complex and adaptive systems all right
and that's part of what I'm trying to do
is to imagine knowledge as an emergent
complex adaptive system which require
for a different which would require a
different kind of institutional
structure all right how can you have
create an instant educational
institution that is an emergent complex
adaptive system that the university we
all know this is rigid time to affect
change in the university is monumentally
difficult these are some of the
characteristics of networks as as I
understand them it won't take the time
now to go over all of those but sort of
the way my mind feels it's from a book
that I think stands up very very well
Douglas Hofstadter is girdle Escher Bach
if you haven't read it read it he
understands he understood early on how
these complex systems work but that is
much more the way knowledge is it seems
to me and that is much more the way the
world is then the kind of pyramidal
structures of differentiation and
fragmentation that that we had before
again we have to think of the complexity
and diversity of the higher educational
system it's a systemic problem
we misunderstand the nature of students
in higher education today what we take
to be the traditional student the 18 to
22 year old undergraduate we have in our
classes here Columbia Barnard or
wherever that cohort comprises only
fifteen to eighteen percent of the total
number of students in post-secondary
education that means that eighty to
eighty-five percent or what we call
non-traditional students include
everything from from junior college to
students in the state systems on the
line but that's a huge huge number and
for those students who are so-called
non-traditional place-based education is
going to become much much less important
as time moves on all right and
especially if half the courses that
they've taken as high school students
have been online courses right so we
have to understand that we have a very
very small slice of that pie now we can
say that we can continue doing what we
do Colombian Williams are not going to
disappear right but the inequitable
distribution of wealth and resources
between the haves and have-nots within
educational world is every bit as big as
between Wall Street and Main Street
whereas our faculty here teaching a full
workload we all know there's a lot more
to teaching them being in the classroom
but are in the classroom 140 hours a
year at Williams it's 120 hours a year
there places that college at state
schools of like where faculty members
are teaching nine ten courses a year
with with seven or eight preparations
300 students and no tas one of the
difficulties I think also is teaching is
not adequately respected and the sad
fact is that teaching is nowhere more
disdained than at a research university
we're status is all too often measured
by how little you teach all right
research is important it's vitally
important but so is teaching and there's
an imbalance I think we should reward
teaching more and encourage those who
are not doing research or are doing very
little research and that number is much
higher than people will publicly admit
to cultivate skills and teaching we must
also find ways to cooperate and
collaborate with less fortunate
institution or with instant with peer
incision my judgment rather than being
being involved in this arms race
whatever it's about NYU and Columbia to
be cooperating how to find ways to
cooperate and collaborate these forms of
cooperation and collaboration should
involve other colleges and universities
both national and international
technology enables us to cooperate and
collaborate in ways we never have before
for instance does it really make any
sense for every school in the Ivy League
to have a ph.d program in religion and
philosophy in history one that have one
Ivy League doctoral program which would
involve a sharing of faculty and faculty
and students across the system it need
not be limited by physical proximity
1992 when I talked with Helsinki I
guarantee and it was a real rinky-dink
operation because we just had to put it
together with scissors and pace I
guarantee you that within 20 minutes you
forgot they weren't in the same room all
right the technology we all use skype
all the time rev it up you can use that
kind of technology now to to expand the
idea that I had with he'll sink is a
global classroom which anyone anywhere
in the world can sit down around the
table and talk together about things
that matter we could do it then it's
much much easier now but we also need to
think about continuing ways in which
there can be support from the government
that's going to be vital
we need to find ways to cooperate with
nonprofit organization other nonprofit
organizations museum symphonies and the
like they have so many of the same
problems and we could work together with
them in ways would not only be
beneficial for them but would also help
to prepare our students for the world in
which they're going to live and work
because we're not doing an adequate job
with that either now come back to that
and we must find ways to cooperate and
collaborate with for-profit
organizations for profit organizations
in education and otherwise the
for-profit sector and education is much
much bigger than people realize they're
about 3,000 over 3,000 for-profit
educational entities in the country a
lot of them have gotten bad reps and
some of it justifiably so but the fact
of the matter is that we in higher
education are to a large extent
responsible for that when I tried to
start global education network 10 12
years ago I knew this space was going to
be important and I wanted educators
involved in shaping it the reason we
failed and there's a 27 million dollar
failure this was not an insignificant
venture was because of the resistance of
faculty members in the Arts and Sciences
we set it up for profit not for the
profit of individuals but for profit of
institutions probably individuals giving
the courses because it's clear to me
then that if the humanities couldn't
figure out a way to generate profit
they're going to be left standing and in
the dust and our vice president told me
a year ago that moving forward those
divisions and departments that generate
revenue are going to be those that are
privileged that's the reality so how do
we how do we cooperate with some of
these for profits in order to continue
to provide the education that many of us
have committed our lives to to providing
so what do we do about some of this
should be already be clear we need to
restructure our financial model and that
will entail very very significant
changes some of that I've suggested
already with forms of
operation and collaboration we're going
to have to downsize within right other
figures that are very difficult to get a
hand on to get a handle on for me are
the extent to which administrative costs
and personnel have increased over the
last 15 or 20 years in some cases there
are good reasons for that and others
they're not all right I think the I
think the expenditures on
Interscholastic sports and athletics are
irresponsible at this time given the
financial problems we face i think all
inner scholastic and sports programs
should be shut down and the money should
be used for educational purposes since
September I've been trying to get the
figures for the amount for the budget of
Colombia's Interscholastic sports
program of it program and they've not
been forthcoming but it's a lot those
resources could be used elsewhere we can
share faculty we can share students some
of that will involve outsourcing all
right people don't like to talk about
that but it's going to become
increasingly important not all schools
can do all things right we're not going
to be able to offer all subjects but but
not be going to be able to offer all
subjects with personnel with faculty
members teaching here that's where
telepresence becomes another option or
alternative and we're going to have to
figure out as I said how to cooperate on
a global level we're going to have to
reorganize the curriculum and some of
the ways that I've tried to suggest move
away from the the fragmented in silo to
create a more a curriculum that is more
porous that allows for more intersection
in collaboration I think we're going to
have to move toward a resaurian of
certification principles what do I mean
by that I talked about mass
customization I asked the question as to
why all course is the same length why
it's four years on and so forth right
it's a model based upon prints a
quantitative principle that is certain
length of time errs are a number of
courses what if we shifted from quanta
tative the qualitative motive assessment
it's not the number of units you acquire
but the knowledge that you have write
the introduction dementia they have two
doctors once one's an American doctor
which is a traditional certain number of
courses general exams and a thesis in
Denmark the doctorate is much less
common it depends upon the presentation
of a public of a published thesis and a
public defense no courses no exams just
a test of knowledge in that way we could
find ways which would which which would
in what would would involve much more
flexibility that's what we ought to
build it at every juncture flexibility
and adaptability it seems to me we could
find ways to allow students to do that
it then might take one student two and a
half years to get his or her degree in
16 years it has to become more flexible
but we'd have to figure out ways to
assess that sort of K as I said we have
to reassess the balance between teaching
and research research remains important
but teaching needs to be taking much
more seriously I think we need to teach
more that I need agree need to teach
longer because the physical facilities
of most institutions are not being
adequately optimized at the moment is
another one I forgot to put in here and
I apologize for that we have to enable
students to cultivate new and different
kinds of literacies and I think this is
important for for many of you in the
operations here at Columbia that you're
dealing with we're not really preparing
our students very well for the world in
which are going to live and work whether
that's at the doctor level or the or the
undergraduate level at the doctor level
it's irresponsible there'd been no jobs
in most areas of the humanity arts
humanities soft social sciences since
1970 I know I was in graduate school the
year they dried up but we've continued
to turn out students giving them skills
for which is really no market I ever
since then all right I think students
ought to be able
about to be able to produce theses in
alternative media whether it be digital
whether it be web whether it be filming
alike across the board all right I think
they ought to be able to develop those
skills which might enable them to do
something other than do what their
faculty members are doing because
they're not going to do that graduate
education has been a process of cloning
it's to produce students to do what the
professor does but they're not going to
be able to do that so we either have to
stop what we're doing where we have to
find other ways in which students can
develop that can use the education that
we are giving them and i would say that
same thing at the undergraduate level is
what they still have to learn to read
and write in traditional forms to be
sure but again that's necessary but not
sufficient in my judgment working in
multimedia I've done a lot of it it it
creates enormous creative possibilities
you know that some of you work in a pot
graduate students especially are
extraordinarily hesitant to explore
these possibilities because they're
chasing a dream that is never going to
be realized finally we need to
reconstitute the workforce and what I
mean by that and and unfortunately this
is this is what a lot in responding to
stuff I write this is what most academic
to focus on exclusively but by putting
at this point I want you to see that
it's it's it's part of a much bigger
complex as I see it we need to abolish
tenure and impose mandatory retirement
at 70 tenure makes no sense it's
justified primarily people justify
primarily in terms of academic freedom I
don't believe that's the case in my own
experience it certainly has not been the
case and if you actually look at the
1940s statement of the AUP it's the
justification is is really economic in
that academic freedom they list academic
freedom first and then the second item
they list
is economic is economic they then the
statement then proceeds however to say
that all members of the university
tenured or not ought to have academic
freedom which means that academic
freedom itself does not does not rest
upon tenure this is really I think a
moot point because act because tenure is
eroding as we speak the only 28 to 31
percent of the positions of the current
can your attention of the pollutant
positions are either tenure a
tenure-track the alternative in most in
many cases as again we know all too well
is to go to adjuncts I don't think
that's a viable system either you can't
run a program without some continuity
and you can't do that and with by hiring
adjuncts ready where to 1,000 25
thousand dollars I of course without any
health care benefits I think that what
we should do is to move to a a system of
seven-year renewable contracts which is
a review in person person to be renewed
discontinued or whatever why what's
reason again its financial but it's also
curricular curricular Lee it's
impossible to know in today's world
whether an area of investigation that is
that now seems important to do is going
to be important in five years let alone
in 35 years just can't know so you can
making it 30 to 35 year commitment your
tenure a person secondly once it once
tenure is in place there's no carrot
there is no stick it's very very hard to
make changes with attendant when you
have tenured faculty member in place I
sometimes put it this way if you were
hired as a CEO of a new business just
starting up and the board of directors
said to you we want this to be the best
business that you can that we possible
go out and hire the top people and I
don't care what we have to pay them
would you hire anybody under these
conditions lifetime employment no
possibility of dismissal regardless of
performance
you wouldn't do it or if you would your
company wouldn't last long that's what
tenure does that's what tenure does so
you need a system it seems to me that
allows for continuity but flexibility
again at every level it seems to me that
what we have to do is to decry try to
create an institution that can emerge
adapt and change with the emergent
emerging and that and changing world in
which we find ourselves it's a
complicated set of issues it has to be
understood i think contextually and
that's part of what I've been trying to
do both in my writing and in my teaching
and in going public with a lot of this
so thank you for your for your attention
thank you Mark in some ways I feel that
the libraries have picked up your
challenge in some ways and thinking
differently about our relationship with
other institutions many of this room
will know about the efforts we are we
have launched with Cornell University
Cornell University Libraries columbia
university libraries a program we call
to cool with the goal to try to
integrate about thirty percent of our
operations over the next period of time
to the benefit of both institutions to
really redeploy our resources in areas
of new need we also found ourselves
about a year ago in conversation with
nyu and nypl new york public library
realizing the three of the world's
leading research university libraries
sit on this island called Manhattan and
barely talked with one another and we
now are launching an effort to try to
build a a research library for New York
through the work of these three research
universities and for the first time in
the history of humankind a person who is
a PhD student or a faculty member at
Columbia will be able to walk into one
of the research branches of New York
Public Library and actually check out a
book no one has ever done that in
history history of the world so some
really important developments in terms
of building with limited resources a
capacity to do more oh we thought it
would be very valuable to have a
response to to Mark's comments and we've
invited dr. Lydia Lu the TAM professor
in humanities and professor of Chinese
and comparative literature in the
department of east asian languages and
culture at columbia she's also the
director of graduate studies in the
institute for comparative literature and
society she is regarded as one of the
nation's foremost scholars in modern
Chinese literature and culture she has
published widely in literary theory
cultural translation material culture
and postdoctoral Empire studies her book
The Clash of Empires examined the earth
shattering encounters between the
British Empire and the Qing Qing Qing
Dynasty
during the Opium Wars her latest book
which is published by the University of
Chicago Press is titled the Freudian
robot digital media and the future of
the unconscious so this is an individual
who works in creative and innovative way
innovative ways across across many
fields of study and so we've invited dr.
Liu to provide a response today Livia
mark and I have had numerous
conversations about the changing
landscape of higher education and
technologically developed developments
and also networked society last spring
he organized a faculty research seminar
on the subject network and we had many
discussions there after his book came
out and I read it and we also have
exchanged some views in private I'm very
happy to have this opportunity to have
an open conversation here I think this
book has succeeded in forcing us to
confront some major problems in higher
education what he calls a crisis and I
think he offers some powerful arguments
about the escalating cost of college
education as you have seen and the ants
and the unsustainable ability of how
universities are managed and we see a
boat vision here and the I'm
particularly interested in what he has
proposed in the book and also what he
has discussed briefly today as the
emerge emerging zone of inquiry in fact
he has already started an experiment in
the Department of religion in
restructuring the curriculum there the
zones that he just described and i was
very tempted here and I was persuaded by
Mark to teach in one of the zones in
maybe next after next year when I
returned from my sabbatical leave
his book he also described some of his
experiments back when he was still
teaching at Williams College one course
that really struck me is called the real
fakes in which he involved a good number
of faculty members from very different
disciplinary disciplinary backgrounds it
looked like the kind of courses that i
would like to teach but it's not easy I
since I teach in the Department is Asian
languages and cultures and also in in
the Institute of comparative religion
society this institute requires some
courses that would involve a team
teaching preferably between a humanist
and the social scientist we've had some
major difficulty in recruiting social
scientists to teach some courses I
bought one course with a historian
victoria de grazia on technologies of
empire two years ago that went very well
I also learned a lot from teaching that
course but um as a rule we've had
difficulty asking sort of around and
social scientists would you be willing
to teach this in that course it's really
difficult this is you know of course can
this can be explained by what mark says
that the walls you know divisions how do
we break down the walls I think mark has
raised some very good questions and how
do we reorganize the production of
knowledge in his bookies proposed some
solutions which may sound drastic to a
lot of my colleagues and because you
would have to shake up the entire
Institute institutional basis you know
how do you do this
and I think you'll be interesting to do
some experiments you know within certain
areas I think it's good that mark has
studied the experiment in the Department
of religion now I also think the
academic commons is a wonderful idea and
I sometimes get anecdotal accounts from
students abroad who say that they use
open online courses on the website these
are a limited availability and I checked
and they told me well y'all Yale
University and MIT they have these free
online courses that we find very useful
you know students in China for instance
okay so there is this awareness of what
might be the best way of making these
resources available to people elsewhere
now mark mentioned that he experimented
with the for-profit online course
project but but failed but of course
there are other people who are still
experimenting and and this is still
going on and I would be curious to see
what the future of that will be and now
this is something that I also raised
with mark Mark's book crisis on campus
presents us both a financial argument
and an intellectual argument against the
status quo and I think it also presented
these arguments today it actually
preempts knee-jerk reactions against
change I think this is very good but not
being a university administrator I'm
speaking more in you know as
faculty member I'm more persuaded by the
intellectual argument because we cannot
pretend that the world has not changed
or the digital revolution of network
culture isn't here now but if the old
con thien model new look no longer fits
a global network society should
capitalism be the driving engine on both
wall street and campus walk now so my
question for mark is whether there is a
point where his financial argument will
come into conflict with his intellectual
argument as how higher education should
be reimagined and restructured and what
would you do for instance when you see a
conflict between the demand of a company
that invests in a biogenetic lab lab
research and the objective of of some
other scientific as a scientific
research that obeys some other logic
should the faculty member that make a
compromise I think this is of course a
point that has already been raised by a
lot of people including our former
Provost Jonathan Cohen his recent book
and also derek park former harvard
university president especially in the
book universities in the marketplace in
any case so that these are the questions
that came up when i was reading his book
another thing that really also struck me
as i was reading was when he talked
about the widening gap of inequality he
has the haves and have-nots between
top-notch universities and non elite
schools and colleges his email exchange
with the this young woman college
teacher is really disheartening as to
how you know seriously problem is you
know because the lack of interest in
teaching among eat schools and so how do
we solve this problem and I think he
what he is pointing out is also
supported by other recent studies such
as a book called the race between
education and technology now in this
book the co-authors Claudia Goldin and
Lawrence cats suggest that whether
inequality increases or not is best
thought of as a ongoing race between
education and technology based on their
study of the histories of the US labor
market and educational institutions
golden and cats conclude that whereas
education was winning the race for most
of the 20th century technology caught up
in the 1970s at an has sense prevailed
now the root cause of the recent growth
in inequality is not the faster
technological progress in the past three
decades but rather the sect's that
nation in the level of education of
young Americans so this is the
conclusion that they draw in that book
based on a lot of statistic studies two
or three days ago the New York Times up
at columnist Nicholas Kristof wrote an
interesting piece called our banana
republic i'm sure you have read this and
he mentions that the CEOs of the largest
american companies earned an average of
43 42 times as much as the average
worker in 1980 but now but by 2000 or
one they earned 531 times as much
perhaps the most you know
Dean statistic according Christoph is
this from 1982 2005 more than
four-fifths of the total increase in
American incomes went to the Reach's 1%
the richest point zero one percent of
taxpayers would get a test tax cut of
more than sixty thousand dollars from
President Obama's plan and they would
get much much more from Republicans okay
so what do we make of this at the time
of nine point six percent unemployment
accordion Christoph wouldn't it make
more sense to finance a job program for
example the money could be used to avoid
laying off teachers and an undermining
us schools so the problem here is bigger
is much bigger here so marks diagnosis
of the crisis in higher education it
really points in these bigger problems
it seems it really requires a major
shake-up of society to address problem
inequality and and and the problem
resources and universities are not ivory
towers but already caught up in all the
tithes of changes as Mark has pointed
out in the in the book now even for
for-profit institutions such as the
University of Phoenix which is discussed
in in his book he's running into
difficulties and because recently
because of the direct entanglement with
financial speculation and economic
bubbles and their stocks tumbled a few
weeks ago so then and so I right to hear
perhaps mark to comment on this latest
development you know for-profit
education if we were to go in that
direction now would the abolition of
tenure solve the problem here I think
our views diverge
we given how serious the problems that
the problem inequality among
universities the rich and the poor it's
a major major social problem and also I
think would be helpful to perhaps do a
comparative study with places where they
have abolished tenure and and see what's
going on for instance is the I one
research institute at Tsinghua
University in China so I sort of learn a
few things from the other side as to how
they the amount is their reform program
programs and that's been reformed you
know from bottom from top to bottom and
everywhere and this is the problem there
because they have some kind of a
seven-year contract problem there is
that people are locked in these
cutthroat competition for company
investments because it's not a consider
a a an ethical issue to invite some
companies to invest directly in your lab
experiment so people lock in these
competitions for companies and also
private investments and also from
government you know resources because
there's a sort of a reward punishment
system there which is directly related
to how how well you can it attract the
funds so a comparative study you know
with you know educational systems and
also the reforms that are under way
elsewhere would then perhaps help us
help us think more about these larger
the larger vision as to what would
happen I won't comment on the issue of
you know academic freedom versus tiny
because you've already addressed in the
book but then I i think these issues
need more careful
consideration and planning that thank
you
I think we have a few minutes for you to
have questions or comments that you
would like to present is if the two
speakers would come up and and be ready
to answer your questions or to listen to
your comments thanks for telling me that
thank you so much for these talks I have
to say it felt as if I was hearing two
completely different discourses just now
I'm somebody who returned to the
University in my mid-50s for a graduate
education and I pretty much total
agreement with you dr. Taylor but coming
from a corporate experience and career
in medical education it seems to me
we're looking at the same paradigms in
both of those fields in medicine you
have this remarkable fragmentation and
intensification of silence a total
inability or almost total inability to
get patient coordination among different
disciplines and different specialists
and the current reforms that we're doing
are basically just kind of pouring more
money in the same system and it seems to
me with education the problem that we
have in both of these cases is trying to
get the entrenched interests including
the faculty and the researchers to give
up that power and money or to make these
changes and actually put the students or
the patients first and dr. Taylor I
could see now why you've had such a
difficult time getting people to
acknowledge a problem what would you
suggest in terms of trying to get the
focus to change more radically I don't
there's no simple answer I think you're
absolutely right on a few days after the
that infamous Abed appeared a student
that I had the first year that i taught
at Williams called me and Harvey has
become a went on to medical school and
become one of the country's leading
heart surgeons and interestingly enough
and this was much before I was even
involved in in all the uses of
technology became one of the the first
heat practices in Albuquerque to use
technologies of telemedicine to to bring
health care to the Native American
reservations across the row and he said
exactly the point that you made he said
what you're talking about is is even
worse in medical school medical
education where people specialized not
only in one organ or one organism or
want one organ but one single disease
and how you tried and the body is a
system obviously and I think the problem
is not only the interrelationship of all
the parts of the system but the
interrelationship with other cultural
have diabetes and was just yesterday up
at my doctor up at Columbia Presbyterian
and diabetes is a ticking time bomb in
the American healthcare system one
attitude a two out of three children now
being born will be diabetic we can't
sustain that now diabetes is not it's a
it's a it's a physiological problem
obviously but as we know it's a social
problem it's an economic problem it's me
it's not an equal-opportunity disease it
requires us to look at all of those
different things how do you bet I mean
I've been trying to argue these points
for over 20 years and the slim hope that
I have is that economic exigencies are
going to make create the possibility for
reforms that rational argumentation
cannot I mean Lydia raised absolutely
spot-on arguments and the work she does
this new book is exactly the kind of
work that crosses these lines that we
need and yet the problems that she poses
in terms of how we affect this
financially it crucial I do think it's
also important for us to be self-aware
about this for-profit stuff before
profit is not simply university of
phoenix that's that's why when I was the
problem when I set up the company 12
years ago to be for a profit the profit
was going to be shared by the
university's not by stockholders we're
trying to figure out because we were
spending at that time 1.22 so just
750,000 one
to 1.2 million dollars per course to
produce costs a lot of money and we were
trying to figure out what Columbia is
already in the business of business big
time the top floor of the building where
my office is technology transfer the
latest figures that I could get from
that operation of Columbia from 2004 to
2007 Columbia made seven four hundred
million dollars from technology transfer
in 2007 which was the last year I found
figures for I think it was 128 million
dollars that was greater than the whole
arts and sciences budget now part of the
problem the Lydia points do is it sort
of like publishing Jim faces problem of
publishing you sell you try to publish
one bestseller so you can finance others
that don't sell as well right that's
part of what the way you have to have to
do this the other thing that's important
when we start a global education network
one of the people who was on my part
board was fab name of John Newcombe who
was then the CEO of Simon & Schuster I
had always vision envision what we were
doing was creating a global classroom
which I thought was a good thing another
the schools were the ones that
introduced the argument of brand
dilutions I thought it'd be I thought
place of the world would be a better
place if everybody had a Columbia
Williams education schools don't they're
concerned about brand I Lucien that was
their language not mine I envision a
global classroom Newcombe always saw
what we're doing as an extension of the
textbook and the the fact that matters
we were both right because part of what
these media does and this now is
relevant for the information
technologies and libraries it it it
obscures the line between teaching and
publication because publishing is after
all rendering public and that line will
change as we move from the scholarly
monograph as the norm to courses that
will take these different different
forms and the like so they're all of
these kinds of ways that we need to to
try to try to work this but I mean apart
from real financial crisis it's hard to
see how you you make things move I mean
either
yes hello thanks for the talk so I have
a question concerning the complexity and
diversity you mentioned if this is true
that there's a lot of complexity and
diversity and university systems in what
knowledge is important and so on what is
the consequence is the consequence that
we have more online courses more
diversity knowledge more different
option for students or should be the
consequence that the university has the
function to to give a strong strong
structure a core knowledge core
vocabulary so I'm from for example a
visiting scholar talking to other
sociologists here then we need common
framework right we need two more or less
have some things some classics we all
know and you said okay it's necessary
but not sufficient but I'm still
wondering if I would if I would prefer
to live in a world with a lot of online
courses with less structure of knowledge
with less knowing what what should what
could we learn and so on so I'm really
wondering what is the consequence form
from what what you call diversity and
complexity again I'm a good question I
mean diversity and complexity I think
our call I mean increasing diversity and
complexity or cultural phenomenon and I
think that that in part is a function of
the networking of the world I mean
that's it seems to me to just be a
descriptive fact having grown up when I
did having studied many of the things
that I have studied I'm always
suspicious about cores and foundations
and yet I understand the kind of issue
that you I want to be clear I'm not
talking about online education simply
for its own sake the question becomes
how can we deliver what I think is
quality education to more people at a
reasonable cost because when you look at
the facts
figures i mean the figures that i gave
you berkeley i think is now up with the
most recently i think a year at berkeley
now is up to fifty thousand dollars now
whether or not the consumer for me use
that pays that somebody's paying it all
right and it's not sustainable so how
how do we do this and I mean the one
question that we never got to answer
with globe Education Network that was I
mean how and I don't know the answer is
how all of this scales you know with all
in terms of the question you raised I
think that part of what is involved with
this is a shift in the role of the
teacher I mean basically the way we
teach at Columbia is the same way can't
talk right you have three size courses
large medium and small lecture
discussion and seminar and when I go
over and meet in my class I stand up
there and lecture right now I have a
close friend who teaches at the irvine
his course in religion this semester has
1000 students in it now there is no
qualitative difference from my in my
judgment apenas students sitting there
within a room of 1000 students and a
student sitting in his or her dorm with
a video clip on it I don't think that's
the best use of that kind of technology
right so you know they're there all
these are going so I do think that the
role will shift more from what
hierarchical authority to meant to
mentoring and advising that's not going
to be less work in some ways it'll be
more work but it'll it will put more
responsibility in the hands of the
student and that's you know and that's
it and at that point I mean what we've
done in the zones with in the religion
department is to develop a list of
suggested books some of which we expect
each student in that area to read and
the rest of which the student will work
with an advisor to work out to decide
which ones are needed for for what he or
she is interested in so there will be
much less of a role much more of a role
in the fight but again these are changes
as I under
stand that I'm not a special that we
have a terrific Teachers College over
here these are changes that kids are
going to come to us having become
familiar with from K through 12 already
and you think those you think a kid
that's that's that's been doing it that
way is going to be satisfied to show up
and be told that he or she has to be in
a certain place at a certain time for a
certain period to sit there and take
notes no way mark you suggested the idea
of multi-institutional PhD degrees and
so bouncing off of that I'd ask like to
ask Lydia do you see it desirable to
move towards an Ivy's PhD in East Asian
languages and cultures and if it is
desirable what do you see are the
principal barriers to getting to that
objective in fact on the PhD
dissertation of some graduate students
from mi you it's already happening I
mean of course because the way in the
same city and it you know faculty do
this all the time you know we have
students who write dissertations and
then invite outside members because we
don't have the expertise among our
faculty in a particular subject so it's
already there except that we have not
sort of structured it in a way that
would make students make it easier for
students to do that I think that is a
rationale for doing this kind of
collaborative work I'm all for it and in
fact I encourage my students to go out
of that way to invite faculty with you
know from other disciplines to sit on
their committees there's another slant
that the end which I think so let me let
me let me take my own Department suppose
there were I mean PhD graduates in every
grat in every program in religion have
the same
there are no jobs so suppose that rather
than having eight PhD programs in
religion there were one Ivy League
program and let's say that that program
were located at a particular institution
you might have a core faculty there
resident faculty some of whom would come
from that let's just take Columbia let's
say it's at Columbia there are four
people from Columbia on that court
graduate program and then ate that would
rotate through on a three-year basis
from other schools it would only be one
PhD program you might still have
programs in all of the different schools
at the undergraduate level but with
fewer faculty at that point so so it
wouldn't just be that you would have the
NYU and the Columbia PhD programs
cooperating but there would be fewer PhD
programs it would be instead of eight we
would have one that would be shared and
there would then be fewer PhDs turned
out all right there would be and again
I'd understand the problems with it
there would be fewer faculty required
and so on and so forth with that but but
you again you're not looking you could
do this with China you have a kind of
joint burrow chat but I mean so would
that be one feasible to deserve one
desirable to feasible in in your Eric I
I think that what you're proposing here
is you know more imaginative than what
is being done in some disciplines and
fields that it is true that we really
produce too many PhDs and there are no
positions but if this has not you know
depends on the field like my field is an
expanding field a lot of liberal arts
colleges in universities are increasing
you know at adding a you know field of
modern Chinese Studies and we we don't
have enough qualified people to fill
those positions so it really differs and
my question is I think how do we then
decide which disciplines and fields
would then need the cluster or should we
you know should different universities
come together and rationally plan things
out and say well we know the next we
project in the next five or seven years
we need to focus on this zone of inquiry
and therefore faculty from these
different universities around the
country all around the world should then
come and train this group of students is
that what you have in mind all right
well this is another enormously
complicated set of issues and we must
also recognize we must also recognize
that the issue of tenure is related to
faculty governance and faculty
governance is also a big problem when
you're asking how do we decide or who
decides and some of these things I think
yes I mean again if you think if you
think but the problem with account
system is autonomy that everything's
seen as separate so we have these
different department but yeah I think we
wouldn't it be radical if a group of
schools came together and said let's
figure out how we can share resources
the model that I just suggested was on
the table in the 1970s and it it wasn't
until the early 1970s that state schools
felt free to allow their institutions to
teach religion in the early 1970s a
friend of mine was hired by the State
University of New York to divide to
develop a system wide program for
religious studies and the system that he
developed was the exact one that I've
described it was going to have a
graduate program centered at stony brook
which would consist of a subset of the
Stony Brook faculty who would be
permanent on the graduate program and
that there would be an undergraduate
program in each of the state branches
over the course of years different
faculty members from those different
branches would be in residence at Stony
Brook for three or four years to serve
undergraduate student faculty so all of
those all of those branches were
involved with cooperating and tried to
set this this whole thing up it was a
much more efficient system than having
five graduate programs in the study of
religion at different state university
branches you don't need them so we could
you know we could do that but again the
only way in which that look here's the
principal competitors have to cooperate
we have to move from a system of simple
competition to cooperation right now is
that radical yes is right part and
parcel of what feeds that competition is
this mania of rankings all right the
college where I taught for 35 years has
regularly been ranked number one
whatever that means tell you dirty
secret president before last no two
presidents ago had as his great
innovation at Williams the introduction
of the Oxford tutorial model as a way of
teaching courses at Williams I don't
think it works for undergraduate the
last president came in and was going to
begin a big new capital campaign for the
21st century and so he they said they
did an educational review this was like
I know it's 2099 about that time they
came around yes and ask people what they
would do about curricular review I said
we can't be serious this is what 15
years ago 10 years ago I see you came
back about spiritual review unless you
abolish tenure and do away with the
departments well that's not going to
happen we developed an alternative
proposal that was basically the zones
proposal in a different variation we
couldn't even get it to the floor of the
faculty right his innovation was to
extend the Oxford tutorial program and
that became the cornerstone of the
capitol of 400 million dollar capital
campaign for the 20
first century why did he do that one
reason US News and World Report rankings
he was public about it Williams had
slipped to number three and the reason
it had slipped the number three was
student professor class ratio the
introduced to correct the the tutorial
program and they not only count so the
way their Tori progress a ten students
sign up you meet in groups of three all
right they count each session as a
course with three students since that
accounting system when in williamston
number one now that's messed up but it
shows the competition in i wrote an
article an op-ed in the times last
summer on this whole columbia nyu thing
when the example i took there was
philosophy merge the department's why
did i choose philosophy because X number
of years ago and why you made this
decision to become the number one
philosophy department in the country
they go out and hire all these people at
very very high salaries you got people
uptown competing with them makes no
sense so trying to figure out ways in
which it can be cooperation and a
sharing of resources so but you know you
know what goes on I mean a couple of
weeks ago when the rankings for these
graduate programs came out everybody
sitting around and pins and needles
waiting to see what we're ranked you
know by not cooperating why not share
resources faculty find it I mean that's
what makes sense in a world of limited
and it does lead to a certain kind of
redistribution I mean Lydia touched on
some of this stuff the young woman she
mentioned is a Columbia Graduate she
went to Amherst she's got a PhD in comp
lit here at Columbia what brilliant
woman and it's teaching under absolutely
impossible conditions over in New Jersey
right ten ten semester ten courses a
year a closet office that she shares
with three other people has to be on
campus X number of hours a day alright
she doesn't have time to read a book let
on to write a book capital is not only
financials also intellectual and there
needs to be a redistribution of wealth
not only financially but I think also
intellectually now that's a
side of another problem Lydia points
through the whole problem of how you do
this within a system that is now
strongly capitalist and and and and in
which they're going to be there's going
to be decreasing support from the
government because I I can't get it I
don't have the figures exactly right so
I'm neither but part of the problem in
California and certainly in other
institutions the same as in other
sectors of society is that that the
retirement and health care benefits for
retirees are soon going to be greater
than the amount of money they're
spending for current employees it's
unsustainable so how do you mean within
that kind so they're certainly not going
to be any kind of increase in
governmental support in a lot of these
areas so how do you how do you make
these kinds of adjustments and not
acknowledging the problem seems to me to
be irresponsible
you